the reason why I'm careful with my I'm
I'm struggling with the I'm gonna be
completely transparent I'm struggling
with being positive because what we got
on Saturday as a guy who fought in the
UFC for quite some time you know at a at
a high level and been in sports for a
high level the product that you got is
we got to be careful because it's not
high level in any aspect it's not a
quality product to production's Quality
the buildup of it is quality the smack
talk is you know effective as a as a
hardcore fight fan you know I bleed UFC
I I love one championship and those are
the sports at the highest level my fear
is we're going down a road where what
you got on Saturday and this isn't a
knock on Logan or Dylan or KSI or Tommy
Fury My worry is that's going to
outshine and overtake the legitimate
Fighters